alright hi I'm saying Meyers I'm a
physician and a senior research
scientist at the Harvard School of
Public Health where I research the human
health impacts of large-scale
anthropogenic environmental change and
the research that I think is most
relevant to this symposium falls into
three different areas one are the health
impacts of rising concentrations of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere the
second is focused on global pollinator
declines and the third is focused more
broadly on wildlife population declines
both marine and terrestrial and their
impacts on nutrition and health our co2
work was really in response to a handful
of small studies in which investigators
had grown food crops in chambers and
greenhouses at elevated concentrations
of co2 and found that they lost
significant amounts of their nutritional
value and those results were sort of
debated in the literature as to whether
they were real or whether they were
artefactual and the results of these
artificial growing conditions and due to
pot effects and so we put together a
group to try to settle this question
including many people who are here in
the audience today as well as a group of
agronomists from Japan Australia and the
United States who were expert in what's
called face methodology which stands for
free air carbon dioxide enrichment and
essentially what they do is grow crops
in these rings of carbon dioxide
emitting Jets and the crops that are
inside the ring are identical to the
crops that are outside the ring with
respect to cultivar growing conditions
whether pests and pathogens but differ
differ only with respect to the co2
concentration at which they're grown
which in this case is about 550 parts
per million or where the world is
expected to be in about 40 years and
when we combined data from all of these
different experiments and gathered it
together we ended up with 41 cultivars
of six food crops growing on three
continents over 10 years which
represented a much larger data set than
all the previously published data
combined and really gave us the statists
power to answer this question fairly
unequivocally of whether or not rising
co2 is threatening human nutrition and
what we found in a paper that we
published this summer was that yes
indeed there are very significant
reductions in iron zinc and protein in
the c3 grains like wheat and rice there
are significant reductions in iron and
zinc in the c3 legumes and less clear
effects on the c4 crops and the reason
that that really matters is that there
are around two billion people around the
world who suffer from iron and zinc
deficiencies today at a cost of about
sixty three million life years lost and
we found that there are almost 3 billion
people living in countries that receive
at least seventy percent of their
dietary zinc and or iron from c3 crops
like the ones that are losing iron and
zinc in a paper that we just submitted
we've now analyzed these zinc reductions
by looking at dietary intake for about a
hundred and seventy countries around the
world and looked at what would happen
with these reductions if people
continued to eat roughly what they're
eating today in terms of the risk of
global zinc deficiency and we found that
somewhere between 130 and 180 million
people around the world would be pushed
into the ranks of zinc deficiency most
of those concentrated in Africa and
South Asia as you can see we're also
continuing analyses on iron deficiency
and protein deficiency that relate to
that the second area that may be of
interest is work that we're doing on
pollinator declines both local and
global pollinator declines and how they
may affect health and nutrition and
essentially we're doing this by
overlaying three different kinds of data
the first is a global database on the
pollinator dependence of all the food
crops that are consumed around the world
overlaid with data dietary intake data
on what people eat around the world and
food composition data that says what's
in that food and when you overlay those
kinds of data you can actually start to
model how declines in pollinators and
pollination services might alter intake
of micronutrients and certain food
commodities this
his work from a paper we published last
month in which we did a pilot analysis
of four populations and countries mostly
in Africa and Bangladesh and found that
in fact there were significant increases
in the risk of vitamin A deficiency for
example in places like Mozambique in
Uganda as a result of pollinator
declines and we've just submitted a
follow on paper that's a global analysis
again with about a hundred and sixty
countries where we've looked not only at
micronutrient deficiencies like folate
and vitamin A deficiencies but also at
reductions in the intake of very
important food commodities for health
like fruits vegetables and nuts and
seeds and overall we've found really
large health impacts including up to 1.4
million excess deaths annually and a
very large increase in burden of disease
the third area where we are working that
may be of interest is looking at the
impacts of human consumption of wildlife
both marine and terrestrial and how
reduced access to wildlife in the diet
may actually cause public health harm
and may not only be a conservation
problem but also a sort of unrecognized
public health problem we've just
completed a sort of deep dive in a
three-year project in Madagascar looking
at a population of 750 people who have
been recording daily dietary calendars
for 16 months as well as giving blood
samples and other biological samples so
that we can look at the correlations
between terrestrial wildlife or bush
meat in the diet and the status around
micronutrients like iron zinc omega-3
fatty acids b12 etc and we actually just
got funded last week to do a sort of to
move that work to coastal areas and look
at a similar set of questions around
seafood consumption and local fisheries
management which will finally feed into
a much larger effort that some of you
are involved in bringing together
fisheries ecologists nutritional
epidemiologists and economists to model
global fisheries management and how the
choices we make about how we manage
global fisheries may pay public health
dividend
or have public health costs so as you
can see this is hugely interdisciplinary
work this is not my work this is the
work of multiple collaborators many of
whom are here who I thank and I'm
thrilled to be part of this effort and
looking to find lots of new
collaborators as a result thank you